we have new information about the
terrible weekend accident west of Albany
New York 20 people were killed when a
limo hit two pedestrians and a parked
SUV bianna golodryga is at the heathaze
at the scene in scary New York beyond a
good morning good morning John this
quaint town of 3,000 people are still in
mourning and in shock this morning
following that crash CBS News has
confirmed that prestige the limo company
involved in the crash had four of its
vehicles taken out of service after
inspections over the last 24 months
Saturday's accident is raising other
safety concerns for the limo industry
there has been a deadly limo accident
every year in the u.s. at least since
the year 2000 those crashes are blamed
for at least 68 death Kris Van Cleave is
in Washington showing us what many of
these incidents have in common
Kris good morning good morning
we know adults say that only about 28%
of them don't wear their seat belt every
time they're in the back seat and in
this limo you don't even have that
option so even if you wanted to buckle
up there's no seat belt back here and
that can be a big risk of this vehicle
is full because there's all of this kind
of debris over here there's no airbag
over here in the event of an accident we
also know that passengers not wearing a
seat belt or eight times more likely to
die in a crash these jarring dash camera
videos show what happens when a
passenger in the back doesn't wear a
seatbelt seatbelt use or the lack of it
may help investigators understand why so
many people died in Saturday's New York
limo crash research shows backseat
passengers are less likely to buckle up
while nearly every state requires front
seat passengers to wear a seatbelt 22
states do not have a similar law for
those in the back nearly half of all
traffic deaths last year were unbelted
all of the occupants being belted means
that it's safer for everyone
Deborah Hersman runs the National Safety
Council and is a former chair of the
NTSB when you have the dynamics of
people colliding against hard surfaces
and against each other in a crash the
outcomes can be significant oh my god
in the 2014
crash that nearly killed comedian Tracy
Morgan and left another man dead the
NTSB found none of the passengers were
wearing seatbelts which contributed to
the severity of their injuries federal
regulators have limited oversight
authority of limos because most don't
cross state lines so the laws are left
up to the cities and states following
this 2015 limo crash on Long Island that
killed for a special grand jury found
limos with custom aftermarket
modifications to accommodate more
passengers can lack important safety
features and urged New York's governor
to establish a task force on limo safety
the report said if nothing changes there
is bound to be another tragedy we should
note that this limousine is not the same
as the was involved in the New York
State crash we don't know a whole lot
about that limousine in particular the
National limo Association did not
respond to our requests for comment but
Hersman says she would like to see
better clarity and consistency in the
law she compared them to Frankenstein
laws for Frankenstein vehicles vehicles
have been modified after they were
originally built
she also says the record-keeping on how
common these accidents are needs to get
better bianna and as Tony had told us
the passengers allegedly texted friends
saying that they were concerned with the
status of the limousine so many
questions still unanswered Chris thank
you and our coverage from Schoharie
continues in our next half hour we'll
hear from relatives of some of the
family members and post friends who were
killed in this accident right now let's
go back to Vlad in studio 57 Vlad you
know you look at an image inside of a
limo and you think of so many people
when you were in high school what have
you when you go to prom weddings the
first thing people that enter a limo
don't look for is a seatbelt they look
for comfort and having fun with their
friends and the images in Kris Van
Cleave story were absolutely horrific of
showing what happens if you are not
wearing to see the reminder about the
importance of because when you look at
that van or that limo it seems pretty
much intact so you're thinking how many
people could die who died but when you
look at that video to see the neck
snapping that way and we still don't
know exactly how they died
but when you can see the neck snapping
that way you can understand why the
death toll would be so high and as you
said earlier you know just in an instant
those pictures from Chris's piece
how quickly it can go to being you know
your goings forward and then suddenly
you're going sideways into a very hard
surface
indeed viana thank you very much we'll
check in with you a little later